well like I said with Avengers infinity
war coming out on DVD we're getting a
lot with that not just deleted scenes
and bloopers but commentaries and
explanations real quick don't forget
about the giveaway I'll be giving away a
few copies of Avengers infinity war
blu-ray all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero so one of the directors Joe
Russo and screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely have given us
a reason as to why Gamora left her home
planet with vanos it's a little bit more
in-depth than he just kidnapped her what
they really say is that he adopted her
air quotes on adopted and on the
Infinity war commentary Marcus says how
does a man like Fanus go about adopting
anyone does he go to an agency does have
to fill out a form
no he kills half of everybody else on
the planet and then you're his this is a
scene that we saw in Avengers infinity
war we saw a flashback of baby Gamora
when Thanos first came to her planet you
see fan OHS line up half of the
population on one side and half of the
population on the other side and as he
is talking to baby Gamora one of those
sides is killed and her parents happen
to be on that side making her and orphan
McFeely added we've always had this
scene from the very first draft it
changed slightly but it was always he
destroys her world and he takes her as
an orphan so obviously from there he
takes her in and he raises her on his
own and he raises her to be this
unstoppable killing machine turning her
into the deadliest woman in the galaxy
and the flashback was necessary because
eventually he will have to sacrifice her
for the soulstone so it's necessary to
see this relationship form and to see
their feelings for each other in the
beginning because they do see something
in each other which the commentary tells
us Marcus says that it was also very
important not for him to just grab her
stick her under his arm and drag her off
and then Joe Russo says that it's
something he sees in her Marcus
commented by saying there's something he
season her and there something she
season him he is a protector even if he
created the danger he is providing a way
forward for her that does speak to her
inherit nature and then McFeely adds
it's an abusive relationship in that way
finishing up the commentary on it Joe
Russo says it implies what is about to
happen to her he steps her outside of
his rule of law which is one side
randomly survives and the other side
randomly gets killed she's in between
the two it's unfortunately a trajectory
she can't escape because it does
ultimately end up in her demise this
makes sense because she's just a little
girl when this happens this alien
species invades her planet she has no
idea what's going on she has no idea
where her parents are and then here
comes big all fan OHS who is kind to her
and willing to protect her what else do
you do as a child in that situation of
course she does grow up and come to
realize that Thanos was responsible for
everything but at that point
Thanos has already raised her a good
amount and turned her into this warrior
and that's all she really knows so she
goes along with it until one day she
figures out a way to escape and that's
what we see in guardians of the galaxy
so that is the writers and the directors
explanation of why Gamora left with
Thanos it's always cool to hear stuff
like this because it lets you get into
the heads of the characters a little bit
more so what do you all think about this
explanation and also what do you think
gamora's role is gonna be in Avengers 4
do you think she'll come back do you
think she won't come back or do you
think she's in Soul world right now let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below last reminder about the Avengers
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero thank
you so much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you